in 1738 a Dutch missionary arriving in
Suriname described the Atlantic crossing
the headwind raged for three weeks I was
sick and miserable for a long time but
the Saviour granted me much grace
finally he disembarked at Paramaribo on
the northeast coast of South America
Johan Josaphat is a descendant of
fugitive slaves from the plantations of
Suriname the path we are following is
the same one taken by the missionaries
centuries ago the journey was arduous
and still is the former slaves live deep
in the rainforest
along with the Bible the moravian
brethren brought education medicine and
practical knowledge no baka didn't know
that's the pseudonym River Moravian
missionaries came up this river that is
bringing us churches schools and doctors
when our ancestors escaped from the
plantations they came here we have to
cross the rapids so it was a difficult
journey that hasn't changed
[Music]
the moravian brethren arrived in
Suriname in the 18th century by then
fugitive slaves from the sugar
plantations were living in the
rainforest the missionaries began
baptizing converts building schools and
setting up clinics in 1722 a German
count Nicholas F on since and off had
given refuge de Mer avians fleeing
religious persecution on his estate in
Saxony the evangelical Christians
founded the community of Han hood the
pious count encouraged them to become
missionaries and to take the gospel to
the four corners of the globe when he
learned to the plight of the slaves in
South America he sent moravian brethren
to the Caribbean and to Suriname en haut
on the Polish German border became the
center of an international missionary
enterprise the suriname river is the
only link between the capital Paramaribo
and the interior of the country
Johan Yosef and regularly goes home to
the village of bata Posse deep in the
rainforest a key because he while I was
walking walk or kayak II this is where I
grew up like you what the moravian
brethren did for us still has a positive
effects on our village waka waka who I
like to come here and see that Network
you know I got so many munis and I like
whenever working the missionaries first
challenge was to learn Shran and Tonga
the creole language spoken by the local
communities that allowed the
missionaries to provide the education
that helped the freed African shape
their own future
the Moravians built a church and a
school like this one
they provided doctors I myself went to
school here until sixth grade yes the
class they go though says the class know
him from you talk you know after that I
went to Paramaribo me I score a key we
taught you something
on Sundays some of the villages attend
services at the local church the
architecture is typical of a Moravian
Church so is the service Moravian
practiced the same liturgy in their
churches throughout the world
[Music]
the sermon and community prayer are at
the heart of this religious celebration
[Music]
let our faith not fail we are prepared
and know that Jesus will return
blessing and honor and glory to him who
was seated on the throne and to the lamb
forever and ever
[Music]
after the service inna palace has worked
to do in the office she looks after the
parish registers including the registry
of births and deaths and issue
certificates when required this function
is traditionally passed down from mother
to daughter the descendants of the
Africans who escaped the colonial Dutch
plantations were known as Maroons after
they established their independent
communities in the rainforest they
maintained many of their African
traditions the women of Suriname have
played a vital role in preserving their
culture and passing on the faith from
one generation to the next
[Applause]
when ena has finished the housework
she reads from the Bible to her daughter
and granddaughter Donna and mom begin
God has appointed his son the heir of
all things through whom he also created
the world he is the radiance of God's
glory and the exact imprint of his
nature and he upholds the universe by
his powerful word the moravian brethren
helped the local community become
self-sufficient the former slaves and
their descendants built boats and simple
houses for their families the women also
took up handicrafts including
traditional wood carving
the patterns decorating the bowls and
calabashes are handed down within
families from one generation to the next
Kuya say madam aku yang no ma no they
are for skills
daddy la quiaca hello Connie see this is
de la quiaca hello cookies in her small
shop edilene sells plastic kitchen
utensils that have brought up the river
from Paramaribo and items that she makes
herself we return to Paramaribo first on
the river and then by wrote the bible
shop is a treasure trove for the
faithful and a meeting place for people
interested in Christian literature
the Bible Society absurdum was founded
in 1966 when reference from the Moravian
Church came from the Netherlands
finishing his study and started the
Bible Society in serum with a small
amount of money which he received from
the Dutch Bible Society and the task of
the Bible Society is to reach everybody
with the Word of God in the language
that is most close to his heart
the official language of Suriname is
Dutch but the various ethnic groups in
the country also speak their own
languages here Johan Josaphat and his
co-workers translate various writings of
the moravian brethren from Dutch into
various local languages most important
at the Bible verses of the day 365 Old
Testament verses that serve as a motto
for each day of the year
Suriname is a multicultural country so
we want to work and to reach everybody
from the different ethnic backgrounds
with the Word of God
driving through Paramaribo with powell .
it seems as though there's a church on
every street corner
the Moravian Church has more than 40,000
members here you have the whining at
church you have the mom aqui aqui you
have the knowledge that scary of the
Kombi church then you have the gift also
also the
hindustani church which is just before
the noticed at scare so there is there
are quite some churches in the inner in
a very small surrounding Paramaribo is
home to many different religious
communities the Moravian Church in
Suriname is not only the largest
Protestant denomination but one of the
most influential forces in Surinamese
society there are various cultures and
religions in Suriname living together in
peace Muslims Hindus Christians price of
street is a good example here you see a
synagogue that's right next to a mosque
the salman africa their neighbors and
it's not a problem
oh no there is a gas pocket black umm
takuna they even share a parking lot we
live together in harmony here leave the
quarter starts Kirk is a wooden
clapboard building in downtown
Paramaribo affectionately known as mama
cocky mother church the Theological
Seminary and the City Mission which
operates numerous social programs are
also located here so a text around the
church which says praise Amara you me
silly Alice an EDC sad a meanie who
prays ahem
Santana which is absolved which has
praise the Lord O my soul and all that
is in me I shall praise His Holy Name
it's about Psalm 103 first one and two
[Music]
basically all the more if in church are
white from the inside if you go to the
other churches in serum you will find
white benches white churches so it I
think it is very similar for for the for
the Moravian Church the building of a
dam to produce hydroelectric power in
the early 1960s had a devastating effect
on many local communities in the
country's interior before the dam was
built all this was forest and there were
some villages in the forest and this is
what is left over after they have built
the dam more than two centuries of
history sank without trace when the
waters rose the Moravian brothers the
ephah hey Lisa brother coming came to
serene Armour and they got permission
from the government to work under the
slaves that ran away the Maroons and he
started about the in a village somewhere
here in 1765 and they built a school a
church and medical post in Ganzi and
Gansey was one of the villages one of
the 25 villages that were here in this
lake when the water started to come they
didn't believe they didn't believe that
the water would come so hard that they
wouldn't be able to live the waters rose
until they covered more than 1500 square
kilometers the local Maroons
demonstrated in vain against the
destruction of their homes and way of
life they were moved to government
established villages in a resettlement
that tore apart the fabric of their
community
so when the demonstrations started for
the league it were the women who were in
for Krong a random women go and
demonstrate they take their children
with them so it was very heartfelt to
see women and children fighting for
something what they thought that was not
right at the bottom of the dam lie the
remains of the 25 villages built by the
descendants of escaped slaves many of
them were Christians they lost their
churches as well as their homes the
Church of Ganci played a special part in
this it was the last Church in which the
residents gathered before being forced
out of their homes with assistance from
the moravian brethren the Surinamese
government provided the evicted Maroons
with new houses and churches and these
included a perfect replica of the can
seed charge Powell Dodds grandfather was
the country's first afro Surinamese
bishop in 1963 he consecrated the
Brethren's new charge yeah dig about
this yes that's the church we saw in the
film my grandfather blessed the church
in net nod up to the mirror when the dam
was filled the people of new Gansey and
new Longley came here and I knew Lumbee
for Powe dot and his wife accompanied by
a senior member of the congregation it's
a heart-wrenching experience he hasn't
been here for 25 years this picture is
the Church of Nancy before the water
came the ceremony conducted here by
Powell dots grandfather in 1963 was
recorded on film
my granddad was standing here a Bible in
the shrine and Tongo language rescued
from the old church is opened at the
same chapter afire my are being go Foofa
Terry who a fire oh the fasting ever
made the laden for power dot the film of
his grandfather is one of his greatest
treasures Suriname is one of the world's
poorest countries many members of the
church struggled to make ends meet and
feed their families tending to the local
community many of whom are deeply
religious is one of system Uriel's many
responsibilities the lady
she said we're going to have the church
in my yard so she built a tent and here
is the church and we can see the fell of
man because the last time that I was
here there was no bail and now there is
a bear many young Christians in Suriname
expressed their faith in practical ways
they get involved in social projects
poverty in Suriname began in the
colonial era and the population
continues to suffer from poor
infrastructure and governance women and
children are often the victims of
domestic violence many seek refuge with
the moravian brethren here they are
helped to find solutions to their
problems from unemployment to HIV
infection today the topic is female
empowerment the instructor explains that
gender issues are all about power he
encourages the women to take
responsibility for their lives and
pursue their goals
with confidence March 2018 will mark
another important step in achieving
gender equality Christian women in
surinam are organizing the world Day of
Prayer if you bring the issue from
gender only from a woman's point of view
we don't get the results that we want
because we want the man to understand
that God said that men and women are
equal I made them looking like me and we
hope from the eyes of the Lord they are
equal there is a balance between men and
women we are not the same but we have
the will if we have the same value for
the Lord
Mary hung Huynh I agree Rudy please have
loss go
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
most of these women will be attending
the inauguration of the new bishop in
the main Church on Sunday the gallery
across the street shows works by young
Surinamese artists muriel held tries to
make contact with them especially the
artists involved in preparing for the
world day of prayer
sorry Yoda chromo whose family came from
Java was commissioned to design the
official poster it highlights a mother
and her daughter the world Day of Prayer
led by the Christian women of Suriname
aims to embody the values of justice
peace and gender equality in the church
and society
Boadicea Oh master right now Doce Panzer
checks on the preparations for his
Episcopal ordination Mokpo and a Cobra
cause as instrument NZ fan often finding
ceremony will be celebrated here at 7
o'clock this evening the people from
many other churches will come the street
outside will be cordoned off it'll be a
big celebration with a choir to honor
the Lord and I am grateful to the Lord
that he has chosen me and I hope God
will give me his blessing what's even
the church is packed for the
inauguration of the new bishop
[Applause]
the presbytery the ceremony which is a
big social event in Paramaribo
representatives of other churches and
congregations as well as high-ranking
municipal officials are in attendance
[Music]
the climax of the ceremony is the
ordination of the new bishop
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
these paper stars are a tradition of the
Moravian Church almost as familiar as
the Brethren's Bible verses of the day
the moravian brethren in Suriname are an
influential church they haven't
suppressed the role they played in this
country's history or their attitude
towards slavery in the colonial era now
they want to shape Suriname future and
be part of a modern society proud of its
traditions for many years this small
country was the object of greed and
plunder fort zeelandia at the mouth of
the suriname river where the capital
Paramaribo was eventually built is a
reminder of the rivalry between the
european powers and their insatiable
greed for new territories there was a
lot of war going on between the British
and and the Dutch and the Portuguese and
the Spaniards they all were fighting for
their for the different colonies and so
now and then a ship from from them would
come in and and they would attack that
ship from the fort the shipwreck in the
Porter Paramaribo serves as a reminder
it commemorates the armed conflicts and
troubled history of a country that now
bears English Portuguese Spanish and of
course Dutch influences the wreck also
commemorates the Moravian missionaries
who risked their lives in crossing the
Atlantic and who helped shape this proud
society
[Music]
[Applause]
holy
you